So several years ago, I was talking to a group of students.
And I was explaining to them basically what's in 1 Corinthians 15.
I was explaining the fact that without the resurrection, Christianity would cease to
exist. And I had it once described to me that it's almost if the resurrection was a
tiny little thread connected to the fate of the world.
And if we were to cut that thread, everything would fall apart.
I was explaining this to my students, and the looks on their faces were
priceless. You could tell that they didn't know anything that I was explaining to
them. It was all new news to them.
They knew the resurrection. They were good Christian kids.
They knew and believed that Jesus had resurrected, and they knew that it had
something to do or maybe everything to do with their salvation.
But they didn't realize that what if Jesus hadn't resurrected?
What if he had just stayed in the grave?
We always talk about Jesus was crucified for our sins, but he was also resurrected.
So there's that second piece of the equation that's really super important.
Then I said to them, did you know that there's historical evidence
behind the resurrection?
direction. Well, that was a whole nother look on their faces that I can't even
describe. It was fascinating, but it was so encouraging to me because I knew that
there was something to be taught here and there was something that these students
were going to gain from what I was telling them.
It's likely that you're going to get some of those same looks as you start to talk
with some of your students about this because so many of students know that Jesus
existed. I mean, let's face it, it's not a new thing that Jesus was a historical
figure. Yeah, you're going to get a few people on the fringe that believe otherwise,
but all mainline history is Jesus existed, he was crucified by
the Romans, he was buried in a tomb, and what?
It's reported that he rose three days after.
Interesting. But there's history behind it, which is why we focus on Paul's
comments in 1 Corinthians 15 to help students start to see the importance of the
resurrection before we dive into the historical reliability of the resurrection.
We want them to really get the whole picture of it, along with the fact that even in
chapter 15, Paul kind of gives a little bit of that historical account.
Like Jesus appeared to people. He appeared to the 12 and he appeared to more than
500 people. And the way Paul says this is almost as if he's saying, hey, they're
alive. Go check it out. Go ask them.
If you don't believe me, it's no big deal.
So as your students are going through their intro experience, we want them to start
to think about historically documented and verified event that happened before their
lifetime. So I want them to go into history.
I want them to see, and a good place to do this is really in their history books.
How much of the Roman Empire do we know about?
How much of Alexander the Great do we know about?
How much of the Civil War do we know about?
How much of the historical events that happened long before us do we actually
have information on? We want them to start to see it because as much as we look at
Scripture because it is the Word of God and it's wholly inspired and it's awesome,
we also could take a step back and say, well, what does this say from a historical
perspective? And what does it say about Jesus as a historical person?
What does it say about the resurrection as a historical event so we want to start
students to start thinking of the resurrection just for a moment as a
historical event so that's what this exercise is really designed to do to connect
them to the idea that the resurrection is actually history okay so for your
storyteller I would recommend going to a local college or a local
Christian high school, finding somebody that's a history professor or a history buff
or someone that really just knows not just history but how to tell history well.
Find someone that knows how to tell the story of history.
And I say that because that's really what the Gospels are doing.
The Gospels are the account of Jesus.
We know this, but it's a story that's describing history.
So if you can get someone that can kind of do the same thing with another piece of
history, you'd be able to help students start to make that connection and start to
see the Gospels as this historical narrative that just sort of kind of wells up and
culminates with the death and resurrection of Christ.
It's a very cool picture. If you do it right, you can paint it really, really well.
We want to make sure that it's not a huge issue amongst students,
but it is out there, and they will run into this when they get to college, that the
resurrection was just a myth, right?
So yeah, okay, Jesus died. And it's a myth that the church made up that he
resurrected. And it's important that we kind of help students see that that's not
historically accurate. And we'll get into more of why that is as we move forward in
the next couple of weeks. But it's important to kind of help students see that that
is something that they're going to hear as they go
into college and beyond. Okay, so students are going to be able to see at the end of
this that the resurrection is actually historical.
Now, does that mean that we can say that this is a for sure thing and that it's
absolute? Well, I would say, yeah, of course it is, but that's a bit different.
But can we prove that Jesus resurrected?
Well, not beyond a shadow of doubt, of course not.
But we can't do that with anything in history, right?
We can't prove too many things in history beyond shadow of a doubt because we
weren't there.
But how history is done and what you'll see even in the storyteller from a
historian is that the one with the best evidence is the one who gets to say what
happened. So the question is, do we have the best possible evidence for
the resurrection? So there's a couple of things that I want to make sure you can
explore this deeper. You can get into it a little bit more.
You can present it to your students.
You can get into discussions about this within your small group time.
If your students want to go a little bit deeper, there's some really cool
things you can do. So the resurrection as history.
Now when we think of history, most people think of well it's the Bible right?
So the number one place that we all look is well the Bible.
Well the Bible could be viewed as a history book.
It's the word of God. We don't want to make a textbook but there's history in it.
Okay that's great. So there's some evidence there.
So we have one piece of evidence in the Bible.
But what do people say? Well, that's the Bible and you can't believe everything the
Bible says. Well, we'll get into that later.
Actually, we can, but we'll get into that later.
But what else then, right? Are there other things?
Well, what about outside of the Bible?
Are there things outside of the Bible that give us clues
that Jesus resurrected?
There is, right? There are Jewish historians.
There are Roman historians that
recorded events about the resurrection, that at least the disciples of the early
years thought that Jesus resurrected and recorded that they're reporting that Jesus
resurrected. So that's important.
There are early Christian writings like
the Didache and letters from a church father named
Clement that talk about the resurrection.
These aren't in the Bible. They're good Christian writings and stuff that we still
kind of use and study in the world of scholarship to figure out what's going on
historically, but that's awesome, okay?
And you've got even now skeptics, people that aren't
Christians are saying that Jesus was
reported as
resurrected.
Now, this kind of raises the question.
All right, well, if all of these areas say that Jesus resurrected, or
at least give us clues to know that people believe that he did, that's pretty good.
Well, maybe there's other explanations.
Maybe there's other things that are going on.
Well every other explanation given has to provide more evidence better
evidence than the hypothesis if you will that he resurrected and when you
do that without going into all the details when you do that they all fall short the
one that says he uh just sort of fainted and that he did wasn't really dead so
therefore he didn't have to you know worry about it uh there's ones that that he was
buried, he wasn't actually buried in the tomb, he was buried in a shallow grave and
some birds and wild dogs ended up eating his body.
There's some people that say, you know, they just grabbed a body and pretended it
was Jesus and it really wasn't. And there's all kinds of different theories, none of
which have the same amount of evidence as the resurrection.
So this is exactly why we wanted to connect it with history because when we look at
other historical events and how much evidence there are for those, we have just as
much or more for the resurrection as pretty much most other historical events,
especially historical events that happened around the same time.
And we'll see that when we talk about Scripture specifically.
So help your students see that this was a historical event, that there's evidence
as a historical event. But just like last week, I would do the same thing that you
did last week. I'd go into your small groups and I would ask them, number one, are
you convinced that it's at least possible the evidence points to
Jesus resurrecting? And number two, if you are convinced, what does that mean?
We talked in the very beginning about the importance of the resurrection, right?
If the resurrection is out there, all of Christianity falls down.
So if you're convinced in the resurrection, what does that now mean for your life?
And what needs to change? What needs to be furthered?
How does your spiritual walk need to go even further than maybe it is now?
What does that mean for you? What does that mean for how you talk to other people
about the resurrection and Jesus and who he is and what the crucifixion and
resurrection actually means and what salvation is all about?
Ask students to sort of not just do they believe this stuff, but have them dig into,
okay, now what? What does all this mean?
What do I do with all this information?
And if they're not convinced and they're still kind of going, and I'm not sure.
That's okay but now is the time where you can start digging a little bit into okay
well what questions do you continue to have?
What roadblocks are there that I can help knock down?
What do I need to do to help bring you along a little bit maybe better to help you
understand these things a little bit deeper?
Is it a misunderstanding? Is I'm just not getting something or is it
something bigger now is the time that you might start to see some
roadblocks in some students lives some walls they might put up they might want to
believe this stuff they might really like love the idea but they might still hold
back and as you walk alongside these students you're going to need to start figuring
out why that is and what's going on and start to that's why we talked at the very
beginning the importance of building relationships because now it's
going to start to really matter if it hasn't mattered before now it's really going
to get there because there's going to be some major changes going on in your
students lives